alors les candidates et alépé candidat
ou comédiens à votre avis la question
est la question est posée
eux qui s'est remis la balle hors moi je
pense pas du tout que ce soit des
comédiens ayant fait cette télé réalité
après effectivement il ya des choses
qu'on apprend à force d dans une télé
c'est à dire qu'il ya une caméra donc on
sait comment se tenir
on sait quand la caméra commence à
tourner mais c'est comme ici sur un
plateau s'appelle l'école a ouais je
vais pas me retourner alors qu'est la
caméra qu'elle a donc on apprend
certaines choses effectivement j'en ai
fait 7 mai j'ai jamais eu un seul rift
ouais mais j'ai jamais oui ça fait un
peu beaucoup mais c'est un métier a par
contre c'est un métier je revendique
c'est un métier mais je suis pas actrice
quand j'arrive dans une télé réalité on
ne donne pas un script en disant voilà
aujourd'hui tu as un scénario tu dois
draguer intel parle donc est-ce que ça
je suis jamais pardon c'est pas cette
émission d'une même d'un même programme
ses sept programmes différents
j'ai fait sept acteurs de complément
justement à voir si actrice alors c'est
quoi votre métier
bah justement je pense qu'on devrait
avoir un nom pour nous qualifier je
pense qu'on vend du rêve aux gens c'est
du divertissement c'est pour ça que
c'est des programmes de divertissement
c'est bien le nom maintenant oui c'est
un métier mon n'est pas acteur parce
qu'on n'a pas un script le matin je me
réveille pas en me disant bon bah alors
aujourd'hui je vais à les embrouiller
intel je vais aller en braille a de soi
même on le fait ça quand même
non mais moi si je peux je me demandais
égaliser la série merde alors je vous
rappelle que vous n'êtes pas invités
vous êtes pays aujourd'hui j'ai des
consignes de monsieur hanouna
non moi je pense qu'on a eu c'est oui et
c'est que j'ai fait discret ce soir et
huit pages vient d'animer le prime des
anges qui est diffusée dimanche donc
j'étais sur le tournage il ya une
semaine donc je peux vous raconter un
peu comme comment ça se passe
moi je pense qu'on a fait une rupture
avec l'enfermement c'est qu'au départ on
avait des téléréalités il est enfermé
sans téléphone sans rien et là on passe
vite
dudu in ou out duo nov et ça on peut
avoir l'impression que c'est truqué mais
pas du tout on peut pas les empêcher de
se parler avant effectivement le
tournage allez c'est pas un truc les
bras là ça tombe pas un peu en rond
alors ça peut des fois
histoire qu'est ce que t'es pas notre
vie combien de fois de vous un revenu
vers vos ex par exemple ça ça risque
c'est la règle générale
j'ai l'impression que de plus en plus on
retrouve les mêmes codes les portes qui
claquent
je parle pas des cas pas des français
qui sont inhérentes à la vie de tous les
jours
exactement je suis d'accord monsieur
monsieur montiel oui et votre vieil âge
vous vous quid encore agendée plutôt les
gagants chérie nous sommes solidaires
tous les deux succès non moi je voulais
me direz je ne suis pas intéressé par
ces émissions du tout je le regrette je
vous respecte la mademoiselle est tout
aussi aymeric tu le sais ouais en
revanche je ne suis pas intéressé
pourquoi parce que justement ça manque
de naturel maintenant tous ces jeunes
qui rentrent qu'ils sont beaux tout ce
que vous voulez mais ils connaissent
tous les codes c'est la recherche du
buzz
ils ont tout compris la saison alors je
suis content que vous avez un statut
d'intermittent peut-être non que maître
assous salariée non salariée
ils sont ils sont intermittents mais
visent tous à dubaï mais papa pas vomir
à quelqu'un qui vivent à dubaï mais ça
c'est pas pareil pour les impôts moi
j'ai fait une télé réalité j'ai fait la
ferme la première poster ball et là ce
qui avait de bien c'est qu'on ne savait
pas du tout ce que ça allait donner
ce que ça allait être donc les gens
connaissent pas encore les codes et on
devait faire des choses on apprenait des
choses et ça a permis de faire une
émission qui s'est très très bien passé
moi ça m'a intéressé parce que la ferme
c'est la base de toute nation de tous
pays
c'est en achètent pour les petits le
livre avec les animaux de la ferme et
tous et moi j'ai trouvé ça génial des
conditions précaires
après bon ça il y avait des questions
c'était naturel quand même on va
demander là on me demandait la papesse
de la télé et et magali très
sérieusement et jamais vous répondez
honnêtement pas de langue de bois
parce que s'il ya une langue de bois
j'arrache une plume thiam est donc volé
après est ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
que candidate et d'arrêter c'est devenu
un métier honnête alors oui c'est devenu
un métier bien sûr parce que pour
supporter déjà la pression qu'ils ont
toute la journée sur leurs épaules les
insultes lynchage médiatique etc
c'est raide il lancé ensuite commencé
brouillard mais il devient à 24 7 jours
sur 7 c'est très compliqué aussi pour
pouvoir l'assumer les castors recherche
des acteurs des acteurs parlent
[Applaudissements]
elle me rappelle le rappelle rachel
trapani qui c'est qui sait si crète avec
un secret je suis dans ces demi de
français ready est jeune on arrache
elles me font des personnalités
extrêmement ils veulent pas des gens
lambda ils veulent des champs qui
divertissent donc forcément il ya des
gens qui soient ou
[Musique]